just I don't have the mean streak in  here and my coach used to say it all the  time like in practice we'd Fly Guys in  they go you got to get meaner you have  got to get meaner you have to I mean  when Steve a was first got the UFC I  flew him into Denver me and him would  have these battles man battles and you  know I'd sit him down he'd sit me down  back and forth back and forth and it was  some of the best sparring ever in my  life and then I married looking at him  just being like I don't think we should  do this man he's like this is great I'm  like no like we're getting [ __ ] up  he's like this is what we need I'm like  I don't think so yeah no I don't know I  just I'm too nice man